Tâm dự bảo khi tự thủy vã khu ra dự bảo đến ngày mai, 1 tháng 1, bảo mắt mò sẽ ở trên bùng viện phía bắt khu vực vã bình đông.
Cái đặc khu hoang xà khoảng 20,000 mệt và có khả năng mạnh thêm.
Xương bảo đến sáng, người xóo tháng 1, bảo sẽ ở trên khu vực đồng bắt mắt mộ, với sức gió mạnh cấp 1,
dật cấp người ba, dí chuyển theo hướng tầy bắt, tốc độ khoảng 20,000 cho đến 20,000 mệt mất dờ.
Và đi vào khu vực mắt vực bắt mộ và sĩ yếu dần, khu vực chứa anh hưởng là vùng viện phía tay bắt khu vực bắt mình đông.
Và khu vực mắt vực bắt mộ.
Tên em ngừng bộ để mùng năng tham mời, vùng viện phía bắt khu vực bắt mình đông.
Có khả năng chữ tắc động của gió mạnh cấp 1,5 mệt mộ đến mẹ hai, dật cấp 1,5.
Sống viện cao từ sau đến tà mát, miện đậu vữ rồi.
Tâu thiệt hoa đậu trong các vùng viện nó trên, đều có khả năng chữ tắc động của giống lốc gió mạnh và sống lớn.